[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 11 septembre le
journal de tv soixante dix huit pour
faire un tour d'horizon de l'actualité
locale bienvenue dans cette édition
voici les titres nouvelle étape dans
l'aménagement et l'élargissement de la
rd30 la passerelle qui surplombe l axe
départemental a été inaugurée hier
piétons et cyclistes peuvent se rendre
désormais et d'elancourt à plaisir en
toute sécurité
le téléthon 2010 9 c les 6 et 7 décembre
mais le marathon pour la recherche
contre les maladies rares est lancé dès
samedi dans les yvelines et les
coordinations départementales
réaliseront un défi logo à l'aérodrome
de chavenay villepreux et puis retour
sur cet événement de la rentrée le 66e
festival de la terre s'est déroulée à
méré un événement pour faire connaître
et pour valoriser le monde agricole
tout à l'heure aussi nous nous
emparerons de nos plus beaux habits
médiévaux pour parler d'un week-end
spécial à maurepas à 18 ans tout juste
qu'on était à perpétrer les attentats du
11 septembre 2001 et deux pompiers des
yvelines ont participé aujourd'hui aux
commémorations à new york est le
commandant marc bédard chef du centre de
secours de magnanville et le lieutenant
colonel sébastien frémont
elle lui il n'a jamais raté une
cérémonie depuis 2002 un hommage et un
voyage que les deux soldats du feu du
département des finances sur leurs
deniers personnels est le 11 septembre
2001 343 pompiers new yorkais ont péri
dans l'effondrement des tours du world
trade center
circuler en toute sécurité que l'on soit
à pied ou à vélo entre plaisir et
l'encours c'est désormais possible la
passerelle qui surplombe la route
départementale 30 a été inauguré ce
mardi reportage d'aurélie ronces de
patrick jacques de dixmude et de margaux
du roi c'est une nouvelle étape pour
l'opération d'aménagement et
d'élargissement de la rd 30
après plus d'un an de travaux cet
ouvrage reliant plaisir à elancourt est
opérationnel coût des travaux 2,3
millions d'euros financés par la région
et le département cette passerelle
permet de favoriser les circulations
douces c'est bien la démonstration qu'on
peut favoriser toutes les mobilités dans
un département qui a par définition une
dominante voiture puisque pour aller
d'un point à l'autre des yvelines les
transports en commun sont insuffisants
c'est bien d'autres les circulations en
voiture en deux roues et à pied qui
doivent être réglés j'ai démarré en 2015
le chantier de la rd 30 a notamment
permis la mise en service en mars 2018
des deux fois deux voies
aujourd'hui au dessus de la rn12 cette
charpente métallique d'une longueur de
122 m et 5 mètres de large
complètent le maillage cyclable jusqu'au
quartier de la clé saint-pierre à
elancourt depuis plaisir on se rend
compte que non seulement c'était attendu
pour les quartiers de plaisir qui sont
de l'autre côté de la nationale mais
également pour relier à montigny sur la
gare et puis aussi pourquoi pas à magny
les hameaux au fin fond de 50 heures
nutriments les travaux d'une seconde
passerelle reliant plaisir le bois de la
crâne débuteront à l'automne 2010 9 pour
une livraison attendue en 2020 une
passerelle que vous pourrez franchir
pourquoi pas avec un vélo électrique
l'île de france va mettre en place une
aide pour inciter à l'achat de ces deux
roues à partir de février 2020 annonce
aujourd'hui de la présidente de la
région valérie pécresse lors du
lancement du vélib ce coup de pouce sera
plafonnée à 500 euros par francilien et
sera cumulable avec les aides
municipales déjà en place
écoutez valérie pécresse au micro de
marylène iapichino et de rodolphe
blondel moi ce que je veux c'est en
finir avec les inégalités territoriales
il ya des mères qui ont mis des
à l'achat de vélos il ya des mères qui
n'ont pas les moyens de les mettre en
ile-de-france notamment quand on habite
dans des villes populaires notamment
quand on habite dans des petits villages
donc le sujet c'est que chaque
francilien à partir de février 2020 et
jusqu'à l'été aura une aide de 500 euros
cumulable avec les aides municipales
dans le plafond de 500 euros ça veut
dire qu'un parisien il y aura 100 euros
de plus que l'aide municipale
mais un habitant de la courneuve un
habitant de magny en vexin aura aussi
500 euros dans l'actualité également un
début de mois de septembre
particulièrement sec conséquence la
préfecture des yvelines a placé de
nouveau le département en alerte
sécheresse les délits de rivière sont
toujours à la baisse une situation qui
s'est aggravée depuis début août sont
interdits notamment lé lavage de
véhicules à domicile l'arrosage des
espaces verts publics et privés ou
encore l'irrigation de grandes cultures
la journée et les prévisions météo
n'annonce pas de précipitations
significatives dans les prochaines
semaines il s'engage dans la fronde
actuelle des communes contre les
pesticides le maire de guyancourt
françois morton interpelle la ministre
de la transition écologique sur le sujet
dans un courrier une démarche similaire
à celle de villepreux cet été le
contexte plusieurs maires de france ont
pris des arrêtés anti pesticides des
initiatives illégales en témoigne est la
convocation ce vendredi de la mère du
perray-en-yvelines devant le tribunal
administratif de versailles et dans
cette lettre françois morte on convient
que les arrêtés pris par ses collègues
maires ne sont pas la meilleure solution
m et comprend leur démarche il revient à
l'état de mettre en place tous les
moyens nécessaires pour préserver notre
environnement et nous protéger des
pesticides estime-t-il élus demandent à
la ministre un plan ecophyto plus
ambitieux dans ses objectifs et son
calendrier un plan pour rappel un qui
doit permettre et d'ici 2025 la
réduction de moitié de l'utilisation de
produits phytopharmaceutiques aller vers
le zéro phyto justement un objectif qui
fait partie de l'ensemble des solutions
mises en place par certaines communes du
parc de la haute vallée de chevreuse
dans le cimetière du mesnil saint denis
par exemple la végétation a repris ses
droits dans les allées plus
de produits toxiques utilisés par les
agents les résultats sont positifs et
encourageants mais le procédé n'est pas
acceptée de tous le reportage de gwendal
saintilan des herbes hautes des fleurs
qui poussent où bon leur semble malgré
les apparences ce cimetière n'est pas à
l'abandon
en choisissant le zéro phyto l'asile lui
mesnil-saint-denis fait partie des 30
communes du parc naturel de chevreuse à
laisser la nature reprendre ses droits
elle nous sommes passés en zéro phyto
complet à partir de 2014
la problématique que l'on a identifié et
est la problématique du cimetière qui
était voilà qui était envahi par les
mauvaises herbes
donc on a travaillé avec le pnr sur une
étude qui avait été proposé à toutes les
communes volontaires pour étudier le
mode de gestion des cimetières dans le
cadre du zéro phyto et pour lequel donc
le résultat de l'étude donné une
préconisation d'un armement
donc on a eu un plan spécifique
d'enherbement et de fleurissement sur
sur le cimetière
le parc de cheuvreux a mis en place une
matinée de rencontres entre élus et
techniciens de la ville un partage
d'astuces et de méthodes pour réduire
l'usagé des phytosanitaires dans les
cimetières
il faut prévoir des solutions
alternatives préventives comme limiter
l'entretien des espaces privilégiés
l'eau de pluie ou encore planter de
nouvelles espèces florales
les premiers résultats sur l'eau et les
milieux naturels sont visibles les
risques pour l'homme et la biodiversité
sont ainsi fortement réduit ces
rencontres ont pour but d'informer et de
sensibiliser aux bonnes pratiques à
adopter dans plusieurs communes du parc
un objectif à répandre dans d'autres
villes
le but de cet événement à mettre
l'intelligence artificielle au service
du renouveau et du développement des
territoires le deuxième forum européen
du secteur s'est déroulée en début de
semaine au château de rambouillet était
organisée par plusieurs partenaires dans
le centre des hautes études du ministère
de l'intérieur est le rendez-vous qui
accueillait notamment une délégation
allemande les précisions avec ce sujet
de manon varaldo et de rodolphe blondel
le deuxième forum de l'intelligence
artificielle s'est déroulée au château
de rambouillet objectif parler des
solutions de l'intelligence artificielle
au profit des territoires avec des
secteurs privilégiés la santé la
sécurité les transports
un plan qui a doté d'un milliard et demi
d'euros
l'objectif de l'état c'est de fédérer
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'intelligence
artificielle l'intérêt de rambouillet
c'est tout d'abord de montrer ce que
nous défendons avec valérie pécresse est
ce qu'elle a à coeur de défendre que la
région et polycentrique tout ne se passe
pas à paris vous avez en fait une région
qui est très diverse
parler des solutions de l'intelligence
artificielle au profit du territoire
c'est la raison de la venue de ce jeune
chef d'entreprise issu de la recherche
de l'institut yvelinois vd comme on
vient pour présenter donc nos solutions
en fait nos outils en termes
d'intelligence artificielle qui sont ici
maintenant de cinq ans de recherches et
qui vise en fait à montrer la
connaissance de la mobilité sur les
territoires donc à l' usage des
territoires pour les territoires un des
thèmes de ces 2e forum européen de
l'intelligence artificielle les
territoires ruraux intelligent ce
quarantenaire installé à rambouillet le
fondateur d'un site internet 1 est
présent sur plus de 37 pays avec
vraiment une note d'une identité pièce
agricole et matin et maintenant matériel
agricole sur le web donc il ya ça fait
déjà quelques années que qu'on y est
objectif pour les collectivités attirer
ces entreprises sur leur territoire pour
développer le secteur de l'intelligence
artificielle
le compte à rebours du téléthon a lancé
à dès ce week-end dans les yvelines
alors que l'événement se tient les 6 et
7 décembre prochain lé coordination
départementale vous invite pour un
lancement dès samedi à l'aérodrome de
chavenat villepreux des défis logo
notamment au programme et pour en parler
christine le coeur bonsoir comment ça
vous êtes la présidente du téléthon de
villepreux qui est directement engagée
dans l'organisation de cet événement
pourquoi lancer cet événement du
téléthon lancé le téléthon niveau
départemental à trois mois
de l'événement national mais en fait ça
c'est un événement inédit puisque c'est
la première fois que ça se produit en
france la fm nous fait confiance
et voilà la coordination nous
accompagnent dans ce projet et pourquoi
pour promouvoir toutes les démarches des
bénévoles les actions qui sont
l'ingéniosité qui est mis en oeuvre pour
le téléthon et ce après par le compte à
rebours en effet comme vous avez très
bien dit puisqu'on est à moins de 100
jours du week-end du téléthon
et ça aussi c'est fait pour mobiliser
tous les bénévoles dont on a besoin
sensibiliser dès maintenant parce que
bon finalement les 6 et 7 décembre ça va
être un marathon deux jours très
rapidement et on peut se mobiliser avant
on peut préparer les choses avant on a
énormément d'associations et on les
encourage d'ailleurs qui sont nos
partenaires qui organise maintenant des
événements avant le week-end du téléthon
et ça permet aussi de mettre l'accent ou
de mettre en valeur encore plus les
démarches de chaque association je pense
notamment au moto club de villepreux qui
organise une sortie moto pour tous les
débutants le 6 octobre
et ça se fait en dehors du téléthon mais
c'est l'argent qui sera pour le téléthon
qui sont entrera dans la comptabilité
des recettes de fin d'année alors cet
événement c'est samedi rendez vous fixé
à 14 heures à l'aérodrome de chavenay
villepreux une promesse un festival de
surprise qui attend les participants un
événement qui s'est préparée on imagine
avec de nombreux partenaires vous
parliez d'une association de villepreux
ça c'est ça c'est fait avec plusieurs
associations
excusez moi alors alors l'association
phare de évident fallait de l'audace
elle s'appelle audace elle porte très
bien son nom puisque c'est l'association
des pilotes de chavenay villepreux qui
ont vraiment a été et ce sont des
fidèles partenaires et qui nous ont
vraiment
ouvert les portes et ouvert leur
expertise aussi quel plus bel endroit
pour illustrer le thème national que un
aérodrome est justement le thème
national cette année c'est la hauteur il
y aura un défi logo qui va être relevé
par par des enfants a notamment un qui
porteront vous êtes venu avec ce tee
shirt on va peut-être le voir à l'image
voilà ce t-shirt de l'afm téléthon
expliqué nous c'est quoi ce défi logo
comme en mai selon une idée folle qu'on
a eue alors les idées c'est toujours
simple de les avoir après pour les
mettre en oeuvre c'est parfois un peu
plus compliqué là j'avoue que énormément
de temps et d'énergie ont été investis
pour préparer ce défi logo c'est une
démarche villepreux ancien avec des
enfants et des parents mais surtout des
enfants qui vont participer à ce défi il
ya plus d'une centaine d'enfants qui
vont relever le défi sur la hauteur
l'idée c'était de réaliser le dessin du
logo avec des humains au sol
on s'est entraîné la semaine dernière ça
a été un grand moment d'émotion déjà un
règne sur l'entraînement donc là j'ai
hâte de voir le résultat achats venait
et
une préparation technique pour pourvoir
pouvoir réaliser ce des techniques
organisationnelles logistique
par exemple les enfants je révèle
quelques secrets vont arriver pas avec
des accompagnateurs en cortège à
l'aérodrome et donc ils sont encadrés
par le moto club de villepreux alors
arrivé il ya une mise en place parce que
fall destiné ce logo au sol donc l
arrivée il ya cei aura cette mise en
place là avec des gens qui se rend sur
place avant et puis là j'ai assisté on a
préparé donc la dernière réunion la
lundi matin avec les corps est la
coordination et puis audace et là je
vous avoue que les prises de vue vont
être faites d'un avion et là c'est ça
devient très technique mais c'est une
prouesse incroyable voilà une route ce
samedi à l'aérodrome de chavenay ville
brûlant malheureusement les inscriptions
pour participer à ce défi sont d'ores et
déjà closes mais on peut venir à partir
de 14h pour cette grande journée ce
grand lancement du téléthon au niveau
départemental y aura plusieurs
animations proposées il ya beaucoup
d'animations je vous révèle pas toutes
les surprises mais je vous assure qu'il
y en a deux tailles
donc il ya notamment quand même des
parce qu'on est là pour la recherche
c'est le principal objectif et pour la
lutte contre les maladies rares dont il
y aura des conférences
trois conférences dans la journée des
gens de la fm des malades qui sont là
aussi des familles pour vous expliquer
voilà ce qu'ils vivent au quotidien les
démarches qu'est ce que c'est le
téléthon et puis surtout ils vont
intégrer un milieu de passionnés les
passionnés du téléthon et des passionnés
de l'aérodrome de l'aviation en fait et
c'est un beau mélange donc j'espère
salle alors que la surprise venait sur
place pour les découvrir vos espérances
pour ce lancement départementale
souhaite une réussite
nos espérances il ya un maximum de
personnes qui viennent parce qu on a
besoin de bénévoles on a besoin
d'ambassadeurs du téléthon on espère que
tous ces enfants vont repartir avec des
souvenirs plein la tête mais les grands
aussi je vous assure qu'il ya des belles
surprises pour les grands et voilà plus
on sera dans le téléthon et plus on sera
forts plus on va récolter d'argent et
plus on va avancer dans la recherche et
guérir de plus en plus de maladies avec
les biothérapies notamment qui sont en
plein essor actuellement rendez vous
fixé à 14 heures ce samedi à l'aérodrome
de chavenay
le prêt pour ce lancement est
départementale du téléthon en 2019 vous
retrouvez toutes les informations sur la
page du téléthon la page facebook du
téléthon de villepreux merci christine
le coeur d'être passé en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes la présidente du
téléthon de villepreux mercredi jour de
sa sortie dans les salles jour aussi de
notre visite dans les cinémas du
territoire ce soir présentation des
films à l'affiché au ciné cette heil en
course et au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude alors dans les salles cette
semaine et notamment au ciné cette le
très très beau film d'animation que j'ai
eu la chance de voir à cannes de zabou
breitman et je ne veux pas écorché son
nom
a gobé mais vd qui s'appelle les
hirondelles de kaboul donc c'est une
adaptation d'un roman de yasmina khadra
et s'allonge en 1998 à kaboul ville qui
vient d'être soi disant libérer du joug
russe par les talibans et où on assiste
évidemment à une espèce de terreur
qu'ils installent des exécutions
sommaires etc etc et on va suivre
l'histoire de deux personnages
principaux deux jeunes afghans qui
s'appelle
mohsen est une alors qu'ils sont plein
d'utopie plein de rêves et qui cherchent
à vivre leur amour tranquillement enfin
tranquillement le plus tranquillement
possible dans kaboul
jusqu'au jour où bruxelles va commettre
l'irréparable je ne vous en dis pas plus
donc c'est à découvrir nos salles c'est
un très très beau film d'animation qui
fait penser à laisser célestine puisque
et léa a travaillé sur le film qu'un htc
festive donc c'est très très fluide
c'est très très beau très très belle
musique aussi donc vraiment n'hésitez
pas à court et et ne soyez pas rebutés
par le fait que ce soit un film
d'animation est aussi avoir dans nos
salles deux mois le la dernière
livraison de cédric klapisch très
réussie à côté de l'encours à maurepas
on vous propose ce week-end un saut dans
le temps retour tout droit au temps des
chevaliers une semaine avant les
journées du patrimoine un camp médiéval
sera installé à la ferme de la ville
rendez vous samedi et dimanche de 10
heures à 18 heures une animation
proposée par l'association locale de
mort pas d'hier et d'aujourd'hui est
aussi par la vôtre philippe lauzon
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
des regrattiers d'histoire alors une
première question pour débuter cette
interview une question même à double
sens qui sont les regrattiers alors
avant de parler votre association
regrattiers je crois que ça fait
référence un terme du moyen-âge c'est un
terme du moyen-âge c'est un site est une
corporation un métier en quelque sorte
qui consistait à les récupérer sur les
tables des des riches de récupérer les
reliefs de repas et ensuite de les
reconditionner pour les revendre ensuite
à des personnes moins aisés voilà ça
pouvait également des étoffes les
vêtements etc ont été reconditionnés et
du coup les votre association les
regratterie regrattiers d'histoire je
vais y arriver
l'idée c'est de restituer cette
expérience alors qu'on va piocher dans
l'histoire on va piocher dans l'histoire
pour le restituer au public avec de
l'ancien on fait du neuf ou avec voilà
de quelle manière vous fait de la
reconstitution au nom de la
reconstitution alors deux
de différentes manières déjà simplement
par un camp ouvert au public un qui
permet de visualiser de la façon dont
nous préparons la cuisine par exemple
mais ça peut être légalement du tissage
ça peut être de la broderie ça peut être
bien sûr des hommes d'armes également ça
peut être au travers des jeux aussi été
utilisé à l'époque des jeux de hasard de
stratégie tactile c'était à l'époque ça
peut être un tir à la corde on a oublié
un peu le tir à la corde mais on peut
faire pratiquer le tir à la corde faire
participer le public autour de faire
revivre par exemple ses activités
j'imagine aussi qu'il ya tout un travail
de recherche pour bien sûr voilà
restituer cette histoire qui n'est pas
forcément d'anachronismes aussi
exactement nous sommes très attachés à
l'historicité de ce que nous présentons
que ce soit pour le porno costumes par
notre table on les accessoires que nous
utilisons nos armure ensuite on utilise
beaucoup ce que
pour en trouver au travers des des
enluminures ou en travers des
commandites et des pierres enfin des
vieilles pierres des sculptures les
paroliers
pourquoi faire revivre le moyen âge
c'est vrai qu'ils ont là on a tendance à
s'imaginer le moyen-âge comme une
période noire une période d'épidémie de
guerre pas forcément une période
positive res est une période
bon on va dire un peu magique dans
l'esprit de chacun quand même oui c'est
une période qui a eu ses périodes
effectivement de guérande désastre de
peste on c'est vrai mais il ya aussi
c'est aussi la période qui a vu sortir
de terre les cathédrales une période
très riche beaucoup de cultures tilt
radin celle avec les moines copistes qui
est recopié des textes il ya beaucoup de
progrès malgré ce qu'on peut penser
c'est exactement exactement alors vous
vous reconstituer plus particulièrement
le moyen-âge au xvème siècle c est ce
que c'est une période très large dès le
moyen-âge c'est effectivement très très
large jusqu'à là jusqu'à la renaissance
qu'on va dire et donc on est plutôt sur
on va dire la deuxième partie du 15e
siècle qu'est ce qu'on pourra trouver
dans votre camp médiéval samedi et
dimanche à l'esc est prévu son look
temps médiéval nous allons avoir des les
jeux là j'en parlais tout à l'heure
donc le public pourra participer pour
s'exercer à pratiquer landais la
pratique des jeux que ce soit des jeux
de dés de hasardeux ou de stratégie ça
pourrait être de voir nos soldats nos
ados d'hommes d'armes au travers de
combat présentation on pourra
éventuellement si on nous y autorise
présente et de l'artillerie
ce que à partir du 14e siècle mais
comment savoir le les canons apparaître
donc on a des petites pièces assez
rudimentaire mais qui représente bien ce
qui était utilisé à l'époque le côté ram
le côté qu'on va être qu'on pourra voir
peut-être des artisans de l'époque de
l'artisanat alors on a quelques artisans
mais bon on fabriquera panoz était bien
sûr ça donne n'a pas changé on n'a pas
trop rond on a de la musique également
des musiciennes qui
on a une harpiste notamment qui animera
on a des peut faire de la danse pourra
faire participer le public a validé
c'est que c'est de faire participer le
plus solitaire participer le public
c'est d'avoir le plus des changes
possible avec le public pour leur dire
ben voilà le moyen-âge c'était ça
essayer de retirer les idées fausses
l'épée qui pèse 10 kg par exemple n'ont
plus qu'une passe par dix kilos de
déconstruire certaines idées reçues on
voit lady plein d'animations prévues ce
qui a des temps forts sur le week-end où
finalement un peu tout le temps ça peut
être ça
au gré au gré de détente du temps qui
passe ça va être bas par exemple nous
sommes d'armes qui vont me faire des
démonstrations d'escrimé de combat ça
peut être peut être également
d'artillerie et le manque est un homme
en forme ça peut être le moment de danse
c'est tous les moments je pense que tous
les moments sont soit en fait il suffit
de discuter avec les avec comédienne
nous à nos collaborateurs car certains
de parler avec chacun se peut être
l'hygiène ou des lainages également
livré un moyen-âge comme on se lavait le
moyen âge c'est très important de savoir
comment quand on se préparait comme un
seul sa toile allons revenir à
l'expression également utilisent encore
la langue française aerolia une autre
paire de manches c'est une expression
qui date du 14ème siècle
c'est ce sont des sections des
expressions qu'on pioche tout droit du
moyen âge exactement
eh bien on vous souhaite un bon candidat
incombera bon camp médiéval pardon merci
philippe loos en vous êtes le président
de l'association des regrattiers
d'histoire oui on peut également se
rendre sur votre site internet pour
avoir plus d'informations ce que vous
faites des reconstitutions un peu
partout dans la région notamment dans
les yvelines 1,15 à territoire avec de
nombreuses églises
il ya demandé ça peut être voilà merci
d'être passé en plateau non merci à vous
et puisqu'on parle d'histoire c'est un
rendez vous traditionnel depuis de
nombreuses années le 66e festival de la
terre s'est déroulée à méré le thème
choisi cette année l'agriculture d'hier
à demain événement pour sensibiliser le
public au monde agricole retour avec
mathilde domini entre les convois
agricoles les bottes de paille les
animaux de la ferme et les stands de
produits locaux
on pouvait trouver cette année pour le
66e festival de la terre la grande
nouveauté la course d'ânes on a mis en
place les courses d'ânes tout simple
dans un rayon avec un petit chariot su
kyi derrière et puis ilan têtus comme il
est bas soit avant soit s'arrête soit ça
soit et ça très très bien marché les
gens étaient heureux voilà c'était un
spectacle les ânes c'est vraiment
magnifique
un lieu de rencontre entre agriculteurs
producteurs et visiteurs
pour rachel qui vient pour la première
fois c'est l'opportunité de faire
découvrir à sa fille le milieu rural on
a fait les tours entre acteurs m'ont
tous les jeux pour enfants
on a participé assisté e
oh moi fao moissonneuses mais là ils
font les balles deux fois à l'ancienne
on a discuté avec les jambes
un festival pour mettre en avant les
agriculteurs du territoire notamment
pendant la pause déjeuner où les
visiteurs peuvent découvrir de nouveaux
produits du terroir nous avons mis en
place une restauration issus des
producteurs donc nous avons proposé le
comment dire le fameux hamburger de
poulet accompagné de des frites donc
frites de jérémy murray à jumeaux ville
et le poulet qui est produit à son chant
donc sur mon exploitation
au total environ 15000 visiteurs étaient
présents ce week-end pour le festival de
la terre qui ne désemplit pas face à
l'engouement des yvelinois pour les
agriculteurs et producteurs locaux
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi dans un instant sur tv 78
premier numéro de la saison du 7-8
société manon varaldo et ses invités
parleront est de la méthode montessori
présente de plus en plus dans les
yvelines quant à moi je vous retrouve
dès demain pour une nouvelle édition
d'information locale belle soirée sur
télé 78
[Musique]